Super Mario maker 2 has loads of new
features in its quartz maker like an
angry Sun new themes such as snow custom
paths for snake blocks and everyone's
favorite slopes but at first it can all
seem really intimidating in this video
I'll be showing the basics of course
maker in Super Mario maker 2 while also
going over how I'd build a level of my
own the first thing you can do in course
maker is choose a Mario style there's
the original Super Mario Brothers Super
Mario Brothers 3 Super Mario World New
Super Mario Bros u and the newly
introduced Super Mario 3d World newer
styles tend to give Mario more abilities
such as ground pound a word of warning
though changing to or from the 3d world
game style will reset the course but
changing between the other styles will
convert things just fine there's also
the course theme which lets you choose
if you want your course to be under
ground in the desert or in the castle
among other things when I start building
a level the first thing I do is think of
an obstacle that is present throughout
the entire level giving you the
opportunity to learn and master it by
the end and in this case I went with the
swinging claw the swinging claw lets you
to make the gaps between platforms even
larger and I felt that was an
interesting challenge to coincide with
the lava in the castle theme by looking
at Mario's trail one of the tools in
course maker you can determine how far
the next platform needs to be you can
also raise and lower the lava level with
course maker but I decided to keep it
stable for my course I think created
challenges revolving around the swinging
claw at first it's a simple jump from
one platform to the other it gives the
players the fundamentals of how the
swinging claw works without any major
threat then they have to do the same
thing but this time with the lava
bubbles meaning has to be a bit more
conscious of your jump time to make
things a little more difficult I
proceeded to throw in a dry bones right
before you have to deal with more lava
bubbles and to swinging claws there
should be a flow to the stage though so
if you decide to make things a little
tough I recommend giving the player a
chance to breathe in this level for
example I just made a platform with
nothing but a check point that contains
a super mushroom sometimes it's also
interesting to throw in alternate routes
for the players alternate routes and sub
areas can really help extend the length
and replayability of the course at this
point the player might think they only
have one option the timer is running out
1up mushroom is about to fall and by the
time you go for it the lava lifts starts
moving but what about the claws above if
you decide to go that way and take my
climbing clawed challenge you'll be
rewarded with a 30 coin and the
opportunity to skip the Bowser fight
entirely if you did stick with the
original route you would have dealt with
more swinging claws lava bubbles and a
Bowser did I forget to mention that the
entire course only has a 100 second
timer changing the timer is another
option available in course maker try to
make the difficulty curve fair though it
can be a hard stage but the best Mario
games don't throw the hardest stuff of
the player from the beginning it
gradually teaches you everything you
need to know along the way however
sometimes it's fun to add a few secrets
if at any time you're not happy with how
your stage is turning out you can erase
undo or even reset the entire thing you
can build stages while the switches
docked or in handheld although we do
recommend grabbing a stylus if you go
handheld since your finger isn't exactly
ideal this stage was built entirely in
doc mode and the controls were a bit
confusing at first but I got the hang of
it rather quickly once your stage is
done you'll just need to clear it in
order to upload it online so those are
just a few tips on the basics of course
maker in Super Mario maker 2 and some
guidelines that I abide by and now that
you're playing with power you're free to
create any type of course you want have
any ideas or tips for stages that you
want to share leave a comment down below
and put in your course IDs we'd love to
try them
[Music]